you got cured tadacip you have your
deodorant sure you have your cozy
clothes got that what did he know black
should they you my water you know mom
and dad my black boyfriend will be
coming up this weekend I just don't want
you to be shocked but he's a Blackman I
never see you like this before brother
Pete family take a road look up a call
bougie bad come back got your damn pants
up to your damn stomach so you guys
coming up from the city yeah we're just
heading up for the weekend can I see
your license please he wasn't driving I
didn't ask who was driving i asked to
see his ID
call me Dean and you're hungry my man so
how long has this been going on this
thing we hired Georgina and Walter to
help care for my parents when they died
I couldn't bear to let him go do you
smoke referrer my daughter I'm gonna
quit she'd take care of that for you how
hypnosis I'm good actually you ready for
this I'm Ben can be so look I go do my
research apparently the whole bunch of
brothers been missing in this suburb
it's cool you're hot you're not scared
it is man didn't see another brother run
it Chris was just telling me how you
felt much more comfortable with my being
named yo sorry man get out yo Rose we
gotta go okay roast keys just give the
keys I don't know where they rose sink
into the floor wait wait wait wait
if there's too many white people are
getting hurt no no no no no terrible
thing to waste
you